you don't cook at all they say I'm
horrible at it and I really don't
[__] like it what do you do with your
kids
um nobody has a cook anymore they have
something called Uber Eats it's true you
gotta do [__] all you got to do is Mash
a butt and somebody magically appear at
your door with food
my family runs the [__] out of Uber Eats
and it seems like the more although open
the bigger my family get I wanted some
fried chicken at the house the other
night it was [__] horrible you have I
I think I killed my taste buds that
night I couldn't even take some [__]
cheese
I put in flowers and then you know I
would have wean you got to break it back
so it'll fold up like a heart that
[__] just kept unpopping and it
won't it ain't like it wanted to fly
this is when I know my food is bad well
my husband forced himself to eat it but
he dumped half the bottle of hot sauce
on it all right this [__] ain't good
girl just ate a whole plate of hot sauce